does a tremendous job of being a high
scorer for the blazers
morant trapped underneath the goal
valencianas will crank up a three and
down the well it goes for jonas
valenciunic
the bridges took the game 111 to 104.
they dominated in the paint
jared against nurkic off the bounce
heavy contact banks it in no whistle
mccullum who who generally raises his
level of play after the all-star break
everybody is able to get to that
environment and they're gonna have to
raise their level of play defensively
right now against jaren jackson jr
okay get out of here i want to wheel you
out of here
as maureen gets the layup to fall i try
to set you up for
gosh you have a chance to gas him up 8
second differential between shot and
game clock john morant gary tran junior
have to applaud the defensive effort in
the first half morant
indecision in the air but good feed to
melton for the dump
so just think jordan if the blazers
played the 482
he would have demolished that record oh
that's a nice move
very nice finish by jackson jr karen
jackson with the
left-hand finish
rant down the middle of the lane brandon
clark his floater is jumping in
clark with a dozen the grizzly now
getting the stops
see if that also the stops the scores
that gives a little bit of pep
moran again dribble penetration floaters
up and in for john moran
his second field goal of the game in the
grizzlies within five
well the other thing about this beside
the engagement of marant
is an attack of the rim in the paint and
john murray you mentioned lamar trying
to get into his group he had the last
layup gets into the paint here
a little flip shot rolls out yusuf
nurkich tries to control it stripped
away
morant short on the bunny jackson junior
tries to get it he gets it to fall so a
couple of offensive rebounds and some
energy on the glass
gets it back to melton who now has two
shoes and they head back the other way
feels like a critical possession for the
blazers to get a stop and memphis
knows that so the blazers take a chance
to regroup as the grizzlies
are hot in their
morant over carmelo for three
five to ten points for memphis because
that could get morant more confident in
being willing to go ahead and release
grizzlies with another steal morant up
and under and
memphis has taken the lead dame kicks it
to hezonja hazonia pump fakes against
allen melton gets the loose ball and
back on the grizzlies
up top to marante
versus the grizzlies
the scorers table at the moment as well
cj working against morant
gets to the right hand side gets past
morant but that gets denied
by jackson jr mccollum oh great
by jaron grayson allen does not have
numbers
jiren for three bingo
trails why not reward the big fella for
knocking down
for playing great defense and then
running hard collins trying to hold his
ground tend to shoot morant dribbles it
back out
kicks it over to the side jackson jr
puts it on the floor tries to get
through and he finishes with the left
hand
and the foul hey jaron jackson jr
loves to go to that left hand on his
dunks
goes 50 right there and the pass by
mello is errant
morant recovers jackson jr for three
and that connects so now the grizzlies
just down three
11 points in friday's win over
sacramento morant attacking and
finishing
good early sign from john moran who
finished with 22 points
and 11 assists here's miranda comes off
of the screen see pearl back defensively
john does a good job of getting to his
spot he loves the defensive challenge
and that's why i said at the top of the
telecast there'll be a lot on his plate
this afternoon
jared on a pat down gets the finish
and the foul brooks and this pad play
here is valentine's away from the basket
nobody on the interior this is a san
antonio team that is not known for the
rebounding but purdle
has done well on the glass early kyle
and no hesitation three
tango elbow jumper
san antonio the two-point lead that
three-point make by kyle anderson one of
two
he's going against the spurs team that's
going to play a little smaller he said
coach jenkins said before the game
tonight
not much of a difference of what we need
to do we need to get to our pace and we
get it got to get out
and we got to attack as they attack the
basket there you worry about patty melt
patty mills from the three-point line
but any time there's a switch
melton on the floor for the first time
tonight another lob that one off the
mark
clark had to reach for it
jaren one on one against rudy gay takes
him to the cup and lays it in
brandon clark going to the basket you
just throw it up and we talked about
jaren
in and out derozan will almost out of
principle not shoot at three
jaren euro stepping finger rolling it
off the glass and it has to be more
jaren jackson junior john moran into
what we call
playoff basketball which is what this is
your main guys
dominate the basketball they make the
plays for your team
and right now jaren and josh in the
second half of that ball game
fourth quarter it's 101 101. boston led
by as many as
20 i know maybe more they started their
march
for the stanley cup no i know what i was
thinking why can't the blue jays play at
home
that's jaren again nice pretty move by
jared jackson jr to give him 13.
see here nice job of being able to
shed the defender he said something like
24 alley-oops a year ago they've had
close to 90 this year
what a different person gay got it back
he's trying to avoid going 0-2 to start
rudy gay corner three
no rebound brandon clark grizzlies get
the stop trying to play with a
little bit of pace here live for jaren
oh
my god morant brooks and jaron jackson
jr on the floor with 12.1 grizzly down
three
jaren steps out for the tie puts it in
oh my goodness jared no
i mean this this this shot here by
jackson jr
this is absolutely amazing i don't even
know if he ever
to help out their various communities in
los angeles and
indianapolis where lauren is from so
great gesture by them
living it things that you're struck by
as you see those jerseys mark
is the diversity nice pass by ja
slips green by clark inside and finishes
with the slam
not bad when you're a big man jaron
jackson has that kind of vision
maximize the three-point opportunities
get in flow and read and react and play
freedom his team plays with a lot of
pace john moretz inside
under two and a half to go morant wants
it back
jaron jackson jr with the mismatch too
little holliday couldn't defend
raptors will be a tough out
under the timeout memphis down 11.
jackson jr with a great spin and
left-handed finish
got nine in the game back to a
seven-point contest great ball fake
by ingram off the turnover kyle anderson
up to brooks and a follow by and
republicans lead the nba in pace
sharon jackson jr blows by zion
and finishes impressively u team
in north carolina out of kinston john
murray left wide open from deep
got it trying to come alive the lead
down to four
[Applause]
you know you're anticipating him going
to the strong side and he's like no you
know i'm going to take you base
he is so dynamic jackson meanwhile spins
in for the bucket
on the restart six and a half for the
season
as a whole morant
doubled over the top valentine's after
gobert came to help
t bowler what's important about tonight
too is you got to take care
of the points in the paint battle
memphis this is where they want to live
they want to live in the paint they're
number one in the nba and points in the
paint they're also number four and fast
break points
aggressive move there by dylan's able to
snake through good hands here by josh
conley with this are giving it up to
morant
and moran throws it down only 14 a game
and they're giving up the steal to
morant
better than two-thirds of his shots come
from beyond the arc
grizzly spread the floor and the leader
is in by moran
not shooting the three ball welder just
one of six but overall they are shooting
52
away you're the away team and you're in
another building you're like you got it
right where they want it
the crowd's really not into it yes
and one energy and when you have a
player the the caliber
of marant he creates energy for your
team with these tight plays right here
got by donovan mitchell accepted the
bump
as we go to rob fisher he's fine with
playing
in the mid post and y'all you also know
that he has the range out to the
three-point line oh beautiful
yeah look away both teams over the limit
[Applause]
morant leads hangs yes and the foul
put on a little bit more weight and you
see again the hang time
marant with a running rebound rizzi's up
seven
their largest lead was nine ja for three
bingo the deck against siacome
and now moran averaging 19 and 9.
works against van fleet reverses it up
and in for the first bucket of the game
but he fell a little bit too soon you
see here one-on-one
vanvleet good defender even though he
dominated
the entire his entire four years at
wichita state
he dominated the ncaa morant and the
grizzlies three triples in succession
to make it a six-point game and then he
would be
right you got an injury you got to get
it fixed right away oh
marantz wow
and talking about the anthony melton
what you see here is
marant one on one no way powell can stay
in front
help doesn't get there soon enough and
morant is able to explode
lowry nice pass ibaka can't finish
valentine's taps the rebound out melted
two on two
wow oh my
couple of emphatic slams
here in the fourth quarter
[Applause]
athleticism off the charts so you do it
two
you can attack the paint a little bit
better than they did against toronto
today
morant to a running valentine's with a
one-handed slam
[Applause]
here in the bubbles you see here good
drive timely pass and you see gordon
hayward
late on his step up there and because
he's late it allows valenciunis
the one-hand finish i had an answer for
his physicality
especially on the offensive glass morant
with a lob for clark with the lay-in
finish
moran leveling off sending it and
scoring it celtics by seven after one
williams tries to tap back the brown
miss but that's
that's the issue that you're dealing
with when there are literally no fans in
the building valencianas and the
grizzlies with back-to-back buckets
let's see here nice pass to valentine's
and again the timing
really coming into his own this season
virtually unblockable
hayward with the foul and an and one for
john moran
[Applause]
morant with nine and a chance force him
to get the ball out of his hands he will
he make the right play as kimball walker
makes the right play there coming up
with a steal
wow marant with a rejection
big mountain to climb grizzlies not
going to
give it up just yet as morant says no to
jaylen brown
[ __ ] athleticism nerdfood partners
good d here by james tatum loses it
another lob and jaw throws it down
he caught it with two hands and just
slammed it with the left
and if you're wearing beale street blue
rolling with marantz always a good idea
all right you see here nice take away
defensively and we all knew what was
coming here but you just want to know
what type finish two hands
last six games in a row longest active
streak in the nba double figure
rebounding for jonas valenciunas
bucks start one of 11. morant finds
valenciunis puts it in
[Applause]
grizzly shooting five of nine six paint
points against the best paint defense in
the nba
but more guys are getting opportunities
memphis playing some good deeds
they are frank nation was blocked ahead
to the corner for a three
a blowout and giannis the best interior
defender in the league nice flower there
by java
but i think it's an interesting
comparison you're giving out bubble
awards and you realize giannis and
lebron are not playing for
he's been the best player in the bubble
for a reason mccullum
knocked away by brooks
anderson to morant moran gets inside and
the grizzlies get on the board
two minutes in or must wins for portland
morant drives left-handed lays it up and
in there's the quickness of john moran
morant shoots it over nurkic sweet
floater there from john moran
but puts portland back up by six
[Applause]
john moran oh sweet move from the rookie
grayson allen the rebound
moran again the burst of speed and
throws it down
this man is duke he's a special talent
coming off of a special year and trying
to
give himself another opportunity to work
tomorrow
john moran spectacular
john morant splits the defense inside
and throws it down